the House of Representatives will vote
today on the revised plan to repeal and
replace Obamacare House Majority Leader
Kevin McCarthy said last night quote we
will pass this bill it gained the
support of GOP holdouts after an
amendment added billions to cover costs
for people with pre-existing conditions
our latest CBS News count shows that at
least 16 Republicans say that they will
oppose the bill it can pass with up to
22 no votes from GOP members so let's
bring in dan diamond he's the author of
the political pulse politicals morning
briefing on health care and the politics
and policy so let's talk about this Dan
starting with this CBS News whip count
that we just mentioned 16 Republican say
that they're probably going to vote no
but is that about what is that what
you're reporting is showing as well I
think so in are you it's it's important
to know that the public whip count is a
little different than the private whip
count that the leaders have themselves
and there are some folks who are on the
fence who may swing over if leadership
desperately needs them it's going to be
close but it looks like they have the
votes as of now okay so here's the thing
though if the bill does pass the House
today it then moves on to the Senate and
you tweeted last night that the bill
would change in the Senate of course and
maybe significantly but health reforms
in it health reform rather is unkillable
and GOP pledged to repeal has boxed them
in so what do you mean by that do you
mean that perhaps the Senate can't
change it that much I love as a reporter
having time to explain my 140 character
yeah so let's take that in pieces first
it's going to change because it needs to
to get support from moderate senators
one change might be more money for
Medicaid expansion more money for health
care coverage those pieces will be
needed to get the folks who are in the
fence on board especially folks like
Dean Heller the Nevada senator whose
state has seen almost 400,000 new
Medicaid enrollees through the ACA I
think the fact that healthcare is
unkillable we've seen a dam where even
this past couple months it looked like
the bill was dead House leaders said as
much and yet here we are on another
decision day so they have made this
pledge to their
voters to their constituents their base
for years and they're very worried that
if they don't follow through that pain
that punishment will be worse than
passing a bill that frankly is very
unpopular and also will have
ramifications it's they're boxed in
because the either choice is all that
appealing yeah and then you'll remember
during the last incarnation of this bill
when they tried to pass it and failed
the president was very influential he
made a public show of trying to rule all
makers over to his side and what he
couldn't Lou them over he tweeted out
threats do we know anything about his
role in getting this this particular
form of the legislation to the floor and
hopefully passing what's he been up to
well I I think it's important to know
Ann Marie that those threats that he was
tweeting out were greeted with shrugs
and and some annoyance as much as
Twitter might seem like a powerful
vehicle for a lot of folks in those
districts they weren't worried so much
about the random tweet from the
President and more about what they had
said their voters and if what they would
tell them if reform didn't go through so
the president in some ways has played a
smaller role in this revived health care
bill these past few months Mike Pence
Reince Priebus have been more
appointment for the White House but they
brought Trump in at the end to give
dozens of calls to moderates on the
fence
sometimes that's been helpful other
times those moderates representative
charlie Denton Pennsylvania has said I
still can't do it for this so he's been
used strategically but he's not at at
the forefront the way that he was
earlier in the effort you know we've
seen video from some of these town hall
meetings that gets really really heated
often they are heated about health care
during the last incarnation of this bill
it was more conservative members of the
party who did not like what they saw now
it was the more moderate members of the
party that the Donald Trump had to
convince will all the members of the
party be able to go back home to their
districts and trumpet this bill if you
will is this something that they're the
members of their of their districts will
be happy with I think that's going to be
one of the defining questions of the
next year and a half no matter what
happens this bill is now going to get a
House vote there will be hundreds of
House Republicans who
we'll have voted to repeal major parts
of the Affordable Care Act which touches
millions and millions of people this
bill is not popular
there is no poll that I have seen Anne
Murray that says that the majority of
the country is in favor and in fact in
about two-thirds of Republican districts
the bill is less popular than the ACA by
a considerable margin so there will be
some holding to account among the
broader population it's among the
Republican base that these congressmen
are worried about that the Republican
base so badly once Obamacare repealed
that if they if these lawmakers don't do
it they're worried about facing
challenges from conservatives next year
so if the Republicans pass this bill
does this mean that health care now
lands in the lap of the Republican Party
you know up until now they've been able
to blame the Democrats blame President
Obama for the faults in the health care
system does this mean they pass that
baton to themselves i I think you've
kind of answered the question with with
what we've been talking about they
clearly own it already every poll that
I've seen has showed the majority of the
country thinks that if President Trump
in the Republicans changed the
Affordable Care Act change the health
care system can't blame that on
Democrats Republicans control the
government at this point and the more
changes in more reforms that they push
the more it will be linked to the
Republicans throughout this year and
into the 2018 midterms dan diamond a
political thank you so much Dan Thank
You Ann Marie